this spice mixture is
phenomenal you should be jealous of me
that i get to smell it and you cannot
hey this is so exciting i am mindy
kaling and i am in the tasty kitchen
with my friend halwa hassan the chef her
amazing book in baby's kitchen is great
we're actually doing a recipe from it
hello what are we making today we're
going to be making a sugar salad which
is a somali pasta sauce we're going to
talk about what makes it special and
different and how it makes me nostalgic
for home i think this will be fun
because a lot of somali cuisine is
heavily influenced by indian cooking so
i was lucky enough to meet hawa through
unhcr the u.n refugee agency and hala is
actually a former refugee so we're going
to talk about our story a little bit and
cook what more could you want
so what makes this pasta sauce
incredibly special is that all the
flavors of the indian ocean are present
in it we have a stick of cinnamon cumin
coriander black peppercorn cardamon
whole cloves and some turmeric i'm very
intimidated by this already i'm not
gonna lie don't be at all it's very much
like garam masala okay i'm sure you're
using your everyday cooking at home okay
can we just stop the way that she said
garam masala i'm indian okay that put me
to shame so i'm just gonna take a heavy
pot and just crush this a bit do you
want to do it yeah if you have some
frustration to get out i would love that
i do thank you while you do that i'm
going to go ahead and throw everything
on our stove i'm going to let this come
to smell about two minutes over medium
heat i don't want it to burn and then
we'll go ahead and grind it so can you
smell it yeah this is like i just want
to waft this into my face for all of
eternity i have a spice grinder i'll
just go ahead and transfer it so when i
was growing up and we would cook with
indian spices sometimes you would make
something and then the house would smell
like that dish for like the next two
days oh my god or you'd go to school
smelling like it yeah it makes me feel
like i'm at home well what's still cool
is how similar these spices are to
indian spices so somalia is on the
longest coast in the indian ocean that's
not an island i think madagascar is has
a longer coast than us but we're right
on the indian spice trade i'm gonna go
ahead and grind this maybe mindy
actually will do it so now i'm doing the
easy thing oh it's like i think you can
push a button
i'm gonna go ahead and pour it into
there and then we're just gonna make
sure it's super fine okay i'm sifting
like an old-timey prospector looking for
gold i feel like a proud mama i know
look at this that looks really good
mindy look at how beautiful
and again it just smells it smells like
samosas and chana masala and i just
can't wait for this all those childhood
memories are flooding right back at the
smell of hoage i love that we've made
our hawaj we're gonna go ahead and use
it in our pasta sauce we're gonna be
making my mom's sugo which is an italian
word for sauce i have this over medium
heat i'm gonna put about three
tablespoons of olive oil so i'm just
gonna let that warm sous chef you wanna
go ahead and throw in the garlic bell
pepper and the red onion all at once all
at once you got it give it a stir so
again we have this over medium heat
we're gonna let the vegetables soften
it'll take us about eight minutes and
from there we'll add our beef let it
break down add our garage this is the
beginnings of also what samosa the
garlic onion
spice thing that's like how we start 90
of our dishes i feel like in indian food
i would always remember my mom just like
handing me a knife handing me garlic and
i just knew that i had to like chop
everything and then she would do
everything else do you have a little
helper now you cook with anyone at home
there's young people in my house but
they're not helpful definitely not
helpful vegetables are sweating we're in
a perfect place okay great so i want to
hear more about you can you tell me a
little bit about like where you were
born i have brothers and sisters i'm
dying to know yeah so i was born in
somalia in the capital of mogdishu i am
the second eldest of 10 children wow i
know big squad so mindy our vegetables
are completely softened this is a good
time to throw in our beef if you want to
just grab the salt it's a teaspoon of
salt mindy just eyeball it eyeball it
how's that i'll just go ahead and break
this up and i'm going to do three
tablespoons of our hawaj which again is
the bedrock of this recipe and makes it
so much more different than other pasta
sauces do you want to just throw it i
would love that is this a good
tablespoon a heaping tablespoon or a
regular that's great that's going to
keep going let's go ahead and break that
yes okay and then we're going to take
about 15 minutes let our beef brown on
all sides and we'll carry on with the
recipe this spice mixture is
phenomenal you should be jealous of me
that i get to smell it and you cannot so
while our meat's cooking i wanted to
talk a little bit about why you were
forced out of somalia if you feel like
talking about it yeah so in 1990 there
was a civil war that had taken place in
somalia
my mother at the time had four kids and
one on the way and my father decided
that we were going to flee and head to
nairobi my siblings and my mother and
myself went to a refugee camp we stayed
there for about a year and afterwards my
brother and i were sent off to school in
nairobi and in 1993 there was an
opportunity for a little girl to head to
seattle my mom thought that would be
great and so
i grew up in seattle washington just
thinking about the little seven-year-old
you flying alone to seattle it's like do
you remember a lot from that journey
yeah the thing that was so interesting
to me was the food that they served on
the airplane we had olives
and i remember calling my mom when we
landed and i said oh these people serve
eyes and she was like
i don't think they serve eyes and i was
like there were green eyes on the
airplane mom so our beef has completely
browned i'm gonna go ahead and throw in
our tomato paste
and then this is canned tomatoes with
just it's juices and everything so i'll
just go ahead and dump that in there so
mindy go ahead and bring our tomatoes
and tomato paste with our beef to
combine
i'm just going to fill up a little bit
of water and get the rest of my tomato
juice out of there
so mindy is doing a perfect job of
bringing all of our flavors together
i've just turned the heat to high we'll
let this boil then i'll cover it and let
it simmer for about 30 minutes so what
is important to you that people
understand about refugees you know i
think that displaced people are often
have a blanket statement about them and
that they are
infringing on different borders and
they're running to take from different
countries but the truth is is that
refugees are not monolithic
we come from many different walks of
life and oftentimes wherever we go we
create opportunity for ourselves and our
community i'm here by the grace of god
but i'm also here because of the many
people who made way for me and i think
that's when people think about refugees
they should think about what has to
happen in order for someone to leave
their home in the middle of the night
yeah i'm sorry i'm getting emotional
because you read so much and hear about
refugees but then you think about
someone like hawa who came from really
kind of unimaginable circumstances and
is such an accomplished woman giving
back so much through her cooking and her
businesses it's just great we're so
lucky to have her and i'm so lucky to be
cooking with her can you talk a little
about your journey into becoming a chef
i got into the business of making somali
food because i couldn't find it for
myself it was storytelling from a
healthy perspective that's where in
bibi's kitchen was born was how do you
inspire people to cook at their home how
do you inspire people to have longer
tables and shorter fences and food is a
it's a community builder yeah it
absolutely is and now i mean i haven't
tried this yet but i'm already getting
so excited about my first somali food
experience okay mindy let's see if our
sugo is done
ah
that looks
perfect i think so too
looks and smells delicious so i have
some cooked pasta here you want to just
go ahead and toss them on top of there
yes how generous should i be here with
this i mean get crazy okay am i putting
too much on here it just smells so good
that's perfect that's good okay yeah and
then i'm just gonna go ahead and
sprinkle some cilantro right over this
this is how somalis eat it we love fresh
herbs the biggest thing that somali
people do is we have banana on the side
we love sweet and savory i was shook i
had no idea so the food is plated and
this is the moment of truth can we start
yeah okay let's dig in i'm so excited
for you to try it with the banana and
all me too it's so beautiful so molly's
will be proud that the banana's not
sliced hey i'm not thrilled about people
having to see me eat spaghetti on camera
i don't do it in a ladylike
way so good this is so good thank you
mindy we did it together team effort i
barely helped but this is absolutely
this is incredible the banana tastes
amazing with it it's so sweet very
subtle it's like spicy it's not hot it's
just like flavorful and delicious okay
well this was fabulous how i'm so
grateful to you for teaching me how to
make this amazing recipe i love somali
food i can't wait to learn more of your
recipes from your amazing cookbook and
thanks to tasty and unhcr the un refugee
agency for introducing us absolutely and
it was such a pleasure getting to know
more about you and your story thank you
mindy and now we're just going to keep
eating the camera wants to film us bye
everyone bye
[Music]
you